DENVER JUST DOES NOT HAVE THE
FIRE POWER.
JOKIC, INSIDE, OFF, REBOUND,
COLLECTED, AND FOUL ON JOKIC,
DOWN GOES PAYNE AND ACROSS THE
FACE AND HERE WE GO.
>> Reggie: CAMERON PAYNE IS
STILL DOWN.
YOU HAVE THE TWO SUPER STARS
GOING JAW TO JAW HERE IN JOKIC
AND BOOKER.
HERE'S THE FOUL AND THE SWIPE.
HE GOT ALL BALL.
I'M SURE THEY WILL LOOK AT THIS.
BUT THERE'S KIND OF A WIND UP,
IT HITS HIM ON THE SHOULDER.
>> Kevin: THE WIND UP.
>> Reggie: IT'S THE WIND UP
RIGHT THERE.
>> Kevin: YEAH, HE DEFINITELY
GOT HIM IN THE FACE.
ABSOLUTELY, ACROSS THE NOSE.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, YOU CAN
BREAK YOUR NOSE.
>> Reggie: YEAH, I SEE IT BEING
A FLAGRANT ONE, BECAUSE OF THE
WIND UP, KEVIN.
>> Kevin: MICHAEL MALONE IS
TALKING ABOUT HIS MVP, JOKIC, HE
IS SAYING HE IS MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY EXHAUSTED.
THAT'S A LOT TO CARRY.
>> Reggie: ESPECIALLY WHEN OMARI
WENT DOWN.
AND HE HAS PLAYED ALL 72 ON HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR WINNING MVP.
BUT THIS IS A FRUSTRATION FOUL.
HE FELT THAT HE WAS FOULED.
THEY DIDN'T CALL IT.
AND THERE'S THE WIND UP, AND THE
SWING, I'M WONDERING WHY PEOPLE
ARE UPSET HERE.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A FLAGRANT
ONE.
>> Kevin: IT CAN GET GRIZZLY, IF
IT'S A FLAGRANT ON JOKIC, IT
WOULD BE HIS FIRST IN THE LAST
THREE SEASONS.
>> Reggie: BOY, IF YOU ARE
MICHAEL MALONE.
WHAT DID HE CALL HIM, SOFT?
>> Kevin: HE SAID THEY QUIT.
>> Reggie: THIS IS WHAT HE HAS
BEEN LOOKING FOR, RIGHT?
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY ARE DOWN
3-0, AND RIGHT NOW, CHRIS PAUL,
DEVIN BOOKER.
TO THE TUNE OF 49 POINTS.
>> Kevin: JAE CROWDER IS
SUPPOSED TO COME IN.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TO DEVIN BOOKER.
>> Reggie: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I THINK IT'S THE WIND UP AND THE
FLAGRANT ONE.
>> Kevin: THE WIND UP IS THE
MOST.
THE OPTICS TELL YOU THAT THAT
PROBABLY IS.
>> Reggie: AND ACROSS HIS FACE.
>> Kevin: WHERE THEY BEGIN.
>> Reggie: YES.
>> Kevin: THESE TWO TEAMS HAVE
BEEN AT EACH OTHER A LOT THIS
SEASON AND TWO OF THE GAMES IN
THE REGULAR SEASON.
THEY HAVE BOTH WENT TO OVERTIME,
THIRD ONE WAS A ONE POSSESSION
GAME AND THE ROAD TEAM WON ALL
THREE IN THIS SERIES.
WE HAVE SEEN THE SUNS WIN AND
WIN HANLEY.
BY 17-25-14 POINTS.
>> Reggie: HERE IS THE FOUL BY J
OKIC, IN MY OPINION, THE WIND UP
ACROSS THE FACE OF PAYNE AS HE
IS GOING FOR THE BASKETBALL.
HE IS FORTUNATE HE DID NOT HAVE
HIS NOSE BROKEN ON THAT.
>> Kevin: AND GOING NOSE TO NOSE
WITH THESE TWO.
>> Reggie: BOOKER, AND THE MVP,
J ON O CAN KIC, GOING NOSE TO
NOSE HERE.
MAYBE THIS WAKES UP THE NUGGETS.
RIGHT NOW, THE SUNS HAVE BEEN
HAVING THEIR WAY.
NOT ONLY THROUGHOUT THE SERIES.
BUT TONIGHT.
AND MAYBE THIS TAKES A BIT OF
THE STEAM AWAY.
>> Referee: AFTER REPLAY REVIEW,
THERE'S WIND UP, IMPACT AND
FOLLOW THROUGH, IT IS A FLAGRANT
PENALTY TWO ON JOKIC, HE IS
EJECT PROSECUTED THE GAME.
THERE'S A TECHNICAL FOUL ON
BOOKER FOR THE ACTIONS DURING
THE DEAD BALL.
>> Kevin:UNFORTUNATELY OUR MIC
IS NOT WORKING OVER THERE.
THE FLAGRANT 2.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE YOU NOW TO
JASON PHILLIPS.
WHAT DID YOU SEE, WHAT WAS THE
CONVERSATION LIKE?
>> HEY, KEVIN, REGGIE.
WHAT THE OFFICIALS SAW WAS WIND
UP, IMPACT AND FOLLOW-THROUGH
ALL TO THE EXTEND OF UNNECESSARY
AND EXCESSIVE CONTACT THEREFORE
IT MET THE CRITERIA FOR A
FLAGRANT FOUL PENALTY-2.
IN THIS SITUATION.
AFTER THE OFFICIALS LOOKED AT
THAT, THEY FELT LIKE THAT IT
CHECKED THOSE BOXES AND
THEREFORE, DEEMED IT A FOUL
PENALTY TWO AND THEN DEVIN
BOOKER WAS ASSESSED A TECHNICAL
FOUL FOR THE INTERACTION WITH
JOKIC AFTER THE FLAGRANT FOUL-2.
>> Kevin: NOW JOKIC IS GONE.
>> Reggie: I'M SURPRISED, I HAD
A FLAGRANT 1.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY ARE
COMING UP WITH THE WIND UP AND
FOLLOW THROUGH ACROSS THE FACE
OF CAMERON PAYNE.
AND YOUR MVP IS DONE FOR THE
NIGHT.
AND POSSIBLY FOR HIS SEASON.
>> Kevin: BEFORE HE LEFT, JOKIC
DID GO OVER AND SPEAK TO PAYNE.
AND THEN WALKED OFF AS WE SAW.
>> Reggie: I HAVE SEEN A LOT
WORSE THAT WAS JUST A
FLAGRANT-1.
I'M A LITTLE SURPRISED THAT HE
WOULD GET A FLAGRANT-2 ON THAT.
>> Kevin: IT WAS A -- WE KNOW
THERE WAS THE BOOKER TECHNICAL
AS WE TALKED ABOUT.
>> Reggie: AND THE LAST WORD HE
SAID TOO, VIOLENTLY TO THE FACE
OF CAMERON PAYNE.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL THAT CAME
OVER AND EXPLAINED THEIR
DECISION BEHIND THAT.
THE WIND UP AND THE VIOLENT
IMPACT TO THE FACE OF CAMERON
PAYNE.
>> PAYNE, TEEs UP A THREE.
>> Reggie: OFFENSIVE FOUL ON
PAYNE.
WITH THE LEG KICK.
>> Kevin: HE WAS OVER THERE AND
THE CLOSE BY